[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing the new and
upcoming Harry Potter HBO Max TV show
specifically we're going to be tackling
one gigantic looming question and that
is whether or not the show is going to
be a good or bad thing for the greater
Wizarding World Universe for decades the
Harry Potter franchise has captivated
audiences worldwide with its magical
world and beloved characters however
with any new addition to a beloved
franchise there are also concerns and
risks to consider in this video we will
explore the potential benefits and
drawbacks of a new Harry Potter TV
series on HBO and what it could mean for
the franchise moving forward so grab
your wand and join us as we dive into
the World of Harry Potter and explore
the pros and cons of a new TV series on
HBO let's start with the Positive Pros
more Harry Potter content the Harry
Potter franchise is a massive fanbase
and I think that I can speak for most
Harry Potter fans when I say that we've
been waiting for more content ever since
the release of the final movie in 2011.
with the announcement of a new TV show
we can now look forward to more of the
magical world that we love including new
adventures story lines and characters
the show has the potential to explore
the vast and Rich Harry Potter Universe
honing in on magical creatures spells
and characters that may not have gotten
much attention before additionally the
show may serve as a launch pad for
spin-off shows exploring different
aspects of the Harry Potter Universe
such as the Hogwarts Founders or The
Wizarding World in other countries high
production value HBO is known for its
high quality Productions with shows like
Game of Thrones and Westworld setting
the standard for television I think that
fans can and should expect the same
level of quality for the Harry Potter
show with stunning visuals impressive
special effects and high production
values the show will be able to bring
the magical world to life in a way that
we have never seen before I suspect that
with this new technology the Harry
Potter universe will feel even more real
and captivating drawing us deeper into
the story opportunity for character
development the show can provide an
opportunity for deeper character
development exploring the motivations
and backstories of beloved characters
like Hermione Ron and Neville expanding
on that the show has the unique
opportunity to portray the book
characters in the way that they were
meant to be portrayed from book to film
many characters didn't translate
particularly well at no fault of the
actor examples include Cho Chang who is
more confident and outspoken in the
books but depicted as timid and reserved
as well as Ginny Weasley who was
characterized as more fiery and
independent in the books but came across
as more subdued in the films A New
Perspective with new actors and
directors the show may be able to
provide us with a fresh perspective on
the Harry Potter Universe by hitting the
reset button fans can ReDiscover the
magic of the Wizarding World and
experience it in a new new and exciting
way missing characters another potential
benefit of the show is that it could
include characters that were omitted
from the films the Harry Potter books
have a vast array of characters and some
of them were not included in the movies
due to time constraints or other reasons
with the new TV show there is an
opportunity to explore these omitted
characters and give them the attention
they deserve including these characters
can help to fill in gaps in the story
and provide us with a more complete
understanding of the World of Harry
Potter
new stories to explore the show has the
potential to explore new stories and
characters beyond what has been covered
in the books and movies this can provide
fans with fresh content and keep the
franchise relevant allowing it to
continue to Captivate audiences for
years to come increased fan engagement
the show can increase fan engagement and
discussion as fans speculate on plot
points and theories creating a sense of
community this can make the Harry Potter
Universe feel even more alive and
vibrant bringing fans closer together
Hogwarts Legacy with the recent
successes of the new Harry Potter game
Hogwarts Legacy fans are more excited
about Harry Potter than ever I think the
show will complement the game well
allowing both to reach a higher degree
of success all right onto the cons
casting difficulties the Harry Potter
franchise is known for its iconic
casting with actors like Daniel
Radcliffe Alan Rickman Kenneth Branagh
and Richard Griffiths to name a few
becoming synonymous with their
characters casting new actors for the
same roles can be challenging as fans
may have difficulty accepting them in
those roles if the wrong actors are cast
then it's going to be disastrous for
this Harry Potter reboot so I'd be lying
if I said I wasn't anxious about this
aspect of the show disrupting Canon
deviating from The Source material
taking creative Liberties and allowing
the show to explore new ideas and
perspectives that are not present in the
books or films may be a good thing
however it also poses a significant risk
if the story in overall Canon of The
Wizarding World Isn't approached
delicately and methodically then it will
be disastrous Canon is king and the
thought of a decade-long show that isn't
in line with the movies or books is a
perishing thought introducing new
aspects to the story may also upset
purists who want the show to stay true
to the original material risk of
oversaturation while fans are excited
for more content there is a risk of
oversaturating the market in addition to
the core books and films the Harry
Potter franchise has also spawned
spin-off books movies merchandise and
theme parks introducing a TV show does
pose the risk of diluting the brand and
diminishing its value our childhoods for
me Harry Potter is one of the most
Nostalgia inducing media franchises I
grew up with both the books and films
being released and they were an integral
part of my childhood part of me is
excited about the new show but another
part of me feels as if it's somewhat of
an affront on my childhood endangering
the sanctity of a successful media
franchise that has already won my heart
part of me feels like the story already
said everything that needed to be said
let a show May merely be an opportunity
to capitalize on the popularity of the
franchise rather than provide new and
valuable content however while the books
and films are beloved they can also be
seen as somewhat dated by modern
standards a new show may be able to
bring a modern sensibility to the story
and characters making it more relevant
and relatable people to a new generation
of fans this would allow Harry Potter
fans new and old to unite and enjoy the
Wizarding World Together disappointment
introducing a new show for a media
franchise as popular as Harry Potter is
bound to incite some and reasonably high
expectations from fans and with those
high expectations there is a large risk
of disappointing them with the high
profile franchise like Harry Potter
there is a lot of pressure on the
creators and producers to deliver a high
quality show which can sometimes lead to
rushed production and poor decision
making hopefully the creators of the
show take their time as to create the
best possible product and stay true to
the bones of the Wizarding World there's
nothing worse than a project that gets
rushed and turns into an Abomination
Hogwarts Legacy was a great example of
how successful something can be when
there's no rush to Market and that about
sums up my list of pros and cons at
least the ones that I can think of right
now evidently there are a lot more Pro
than cons which is not something I
realized until I put pen to paper what
do you guys think are you excited for
this show what are your pros and cons
for the new Harry Potter HBO Max TV show
which of my points do you agree with
disagree with please leave a comment
down below until next time remember
there is plenty to be learned even from
a bad teacher what not to do how not to
be